hello everyone and welcome to tonight's
episode of beginner breakdown my name is
always is alex and i'm excited to be
showing you this lesson um we're going
to be talking about
autopilot
um so this is something that's happened
to me
over the years especially when i was
younger and kind of starting out in play
at first
you know as a beginner you're kind of
learning the moves and you're learning
the principles and you're really just
kind of reacting and responding to
everything but after you get a little
bit better and you start to you know
make some patterns maybe you
play the london defense and you kind of
just get into a habit of doing kind of
the same thing every time
or like me you play the king's indian
defense and you kind of get into this
habit of just following the same pattern
of opening moves over and over again
the problem is sometimes your opponents
respond in ways that can cause you some
issues
so we're going to talk about that by
looking at two games tonight that both
feature the king's indian um mostly just
because i play it and so i'm very
familiar with it but i think both of
these games one of them i win one of
them i lose and they both show
uh both players in some cases using
autopilot
instead of actually assessing the
positions so that's our topic for
tonight
to start out for those unfamiliar we
always want to think about openings
in line with opening principles
so i think understanding moves and move
orders is important to an extent but
it's way more important to understand
your moves and figure out how they are
fitting with the the grander scheme of
the game
so your three opening principles are you
want to control the center specifically
these four squares it's a great
launching point for you to attack your
opponent's king as well as defend your
own and uh putting your pieces there
either attacking these squares or on
them is generally a really good idea
second we need to develop our pieces
right we need to get our pieces into the
game so knights and bishops want to come
out find good squares to go to
your rooks and queens do as well to an
extent but they usually want to wait a
little bit because they're pretty big
targets if they get out too early
third thing is you want to protect your
king
so we need to get our king safe in some
form or other uh usually we're gonna do
by castling
on one side or the other and there's
some time situations where you don't
need to but usually that's what it means
to get your king safe
so with those three principles in mind
let's start by looking at the particular
opening that features in both of these
games
i'm going to kind of go through it along
line with these principles but also lay
out some of the basic plans so that
especially people who are unfamiliar
will at least have an idea of what each
player is shooting for as we look at the
openings and try and find where
autopilot is creating some weaknesses
so uh the variation that is played in
the king's indian
defense that we're going to look at
starts with d4 this is the main start
right normal opening move controlling
the center opening up space for the
bishop
kind of just a traditional classic move
right maybe less popular at
normal levels than e4 but still a fairly
popular and very very good solid move
nonetheless
and now black continues knight to f6 so
this there's a few defenses this could
move into but by moving the knight um
rather than like a more classical
defense like playing e5 right away
um this is already showing that we are
trying to play a little more flexibly
but also a little less traditionally
right normally the traditional theory of
chess says we're going to fight for the
center immediately with the pawns and
kind of stake a claim in the center
without f6 we're going to be a little
more responsive
so we're going to wait and see how our
opponent chooses to set up their pieces
there's a lot of different things they
can do
and the line we're going to look at is
c4 this is kind of the main way to
continue
because knight to f6 is preventing pawn
to e5 right if if they played that you
would just take it for free um usually
white's going to want to keep fighting
for the center they could play a move
like knight to c3 to immediately push
this pawn
um but
the problem here is this is blocking in
their pawn on c2 so why not play c4
first you can always play knight two c3
later and then play e4 and kind of get
the best of both worlds so that's kind
of the school of thought with this move
here
black continues with g6 again there's
different move things they can do you
could play d6 or some other options if
you'd played e6 here it'd be maybe a
nimzo indian defense but we're looking
at the king's indian and the main idea
here is we are preparing to fianchetto
our bishop here on g7
look at the nice long diagonal and then
get our king castled in this kind of
secure structure
so something to note about the king's
indian and really all defenses where you
are fianchettoing a bishop and then
castling
is this bishop is a very important
especially as a defensive resource right
notice how after we push this pawn the
pawns are really only controlling the
light squares
there's a lot of dark squared weaknesses
so we need to keep this bishop alive in
order to you know defend all of that and
kind of fix it but it is also an
attacking piece on this diagonal so
that's kind of what is happening with
this move here
uh knight to c3 very normal move right
now getting the knight in play preparing
to play e4 uh now that the pawn has
pushed forward so white is just hoping
to continue taking up space in the
center
and bishop g7 now we are committed to
the king's indian defense
you could have played something like a
grunfeld if you played e5
another very traditional opening but
bishop g7 does signify we are playing
the king's indian defense
and e4 uh the main move the most testing
move way is taking up full space in the
center really relishing the fact that we
have not pushed any of our pawns to
fight them
and what's happening here is i know i
said one of the opening principles is
you want to control the center right and
it looks like white's doing an excellent
job of that and black is not well that's
true and if we continue to play this way
and castle our king and just you know
maybe play pawns over here and never
really fight in the center we're going
to get blown off the board you do need
to fight back
but this opening is one of a it's called
the hyper modern school of chess
openings and the thought process here is
we're going to let our opponent pick
some kind of setup in this case it's
this version of the king's indian
and then based on what they do we're
going to respond and try and undermine
their setup or maybe if they've
overextended capitalize on those
weaknesses
so
uh
e4 now we definitely can't play d5 right
this is off the table that's why if you
want to play the greenfield you'd need
to play it first because now there's too
many things defending the square
d6
uh the point of this move is twofold one
we're preparing to open up our bishop
and also we are making e5 less good for
white
in some lines if we don't have b6 they
can just push the e5 and make our knight
move away cause some annoying problems
with d6 that's not as good because we
are going to be able to trade things and
open up the center and weaken kind of
this beautiful
center that white is trying to hold on
to
and now we're going to look at a very
specific line right white has a lot of
options here the main one is probably to
play knight to f3 but there's really
hundreds of ways you can play this you
can play the four knights
you could bring the bishop out to g5 or
f4 or e3 really anywhere with this
bishop
put the bishop on e2 and maybe set up
for some kind of this is sometimes
called the bayonet attack where you're
going to kind of launch with this pawn
and the bishop and queen are going to
defend it there's really a lot of things
white can do
but the two games we're going to look at
both feature this move pawn to f3 and
this is uh known as the samish variation
and it's a solid move that is really
defending the senate
and it's also kind of fighting against
some of the main ideas of the king's
indian so before we get into the
specifics of this variation i want to
very briefly
talk about what kind of the main line
looks like and what are normally the
plants because that's going to help
understand this idea of autopiloting
so normally what's going to happen
is
this kind of classical setup white is
going to develop their pieces
and black is going to continue the plan
castling bishop
b2 e5 right it's important at some point
to strike in the center sometimes c5 is
the way that people play it but i like
e5 more
castles and just something like this
knight to c6 d5
97
b4 and we're going to start to see
really the plans for both sides here
uh we're going to stop at this position
but this gives a good example often in
the king's indian defense and especially
in these main lines
what's going to happen is white is
fighting on the queen side right white
is going to transform over here on the
queen side break through and get their
pieces involved over here
whereas black is fighting on the king
side so black is going to launch forward
these pawns especially with this move we
just saw of f5
and try and push the pawns further
forward to strike at the king on the
king side and often what happens in
these games is the side that wins is the
side that gets their plan through first
or better
so that's normally what's happening in
the king's indian defense and i wanted
to talk about that because in the same
ish the ideas are now a little different
with f3 you can still continue as white
with these plans right you can use f3 as
a supportive move just holding on to the
center a little bit better and continue
eventually with these ideas of striking
out at the queen side
but there's also this interesting option
now where white can instead choose to
launch these pawns right f3 is a great
supportive piece for not only e4 but
also g4
and so there are some real ideas of
pushing forward with h4 h5
and this can cause problems so in these
uh variations white often is fighting on
the king side and black's gonna have to
fight on the queen side where normally
it's the other way around
so keep that in mind because that's
going to show up
uh in the variations we're going to look
at black castles
and white plays bishop to e3
which not only defends this d4 pawn but
has kind of another idea queen d2 is
often coming followed by queenside
castles and this bishop and queen are
going to look at this diagonal so for
instance
something like e5 queen d2
i guess you can take here so maybe queen
d2 wouldn't be so good there but you
know something like this
instead the move that i play instead of
something like e5 i play this move
knight a6 and it's pretty weird um it's
a pet line of mine that i kind of like
but it's actually i think much more
effective against the main line than it
is against the same edge and we're going
to talk about why as we see what's going
on in these games
so
kind of the point here is it looks weird
to put this knight on the edge but often
the knight wants to jump in either to b4
and cause some problems over here
or to c5 or even sometimes to c7 once
this pawn has moved
so that's kind of the idea so one
example line might be something like
queen d2 e5 striking at the center
d5 pushing past locking things up
and knight to c5
and this is what we're going to look at
in both of the games that happen tonight
black has centralized the knight
white has locked down the center and has
this really nice pawn chain
and there's really pros and cons for
both players
a few quick alternatives i don't want to
get too lost in the opening without
talking about the main theme
but there are some other options here
instead of knight a6
but after knight a6 has been played
and queen d2 again serving to help the
king castle and also eventually
threatening to play this bishop to h6
move why would white want to do this
well this battery is really helpful
because as we said this dark squared
bishop plays a very important role of
defending these dark squares right the
pawns now are defending the light
squares the bishop needs to defend the
dark squares so if white can remove both
of these bishops they're going to do
a great service to themselves right
they're going to make
black's castle a lot weaker
e5 sometimes c5 does happen here this is
actually i think more common in the
knight a6 line uh with the idea of now
bringing the knight back to c7 and
sometimes forwards to b4
um
and if the pawn takes then the knight is
either right now or eventually ready to
occupy this c5 square um if white were
to trade this would all be very happy
for black one their bishop is no longer
able to trade for ours and we've also
opened up these lines
broken away like center so this would be
something very very happy for black
but e5
and there's a lot of options here and my
opponent has always chosen the five in
both of these games they could castle
here and allow takes they could defend
the pawn but again without getting too
bogged down in opening theory um we're
going to look at what actually has
happened in these two games
and so this is going to be our starting
position
so keep this one in mind and kind of how
we got here i'm going to breeze through
it a little bit in the next two games
but i want to give some backstory for
these two games so both of these games
were played between me i had the black
pieces and my opponent was mike cummer
who you may recognize from several of
these uh several of the videos on our
channel he's done beginner breakdown in
the past but a lot of other things as
well really awesome part of our
community here at the chess club
and uh he's played me in this position
exactly twice
um
the first one happened in late 2020 i
want to say it was november
and this game i actually ended up
winning but let's see what happens so we
again enter this position and all of the
ideas i just spoke of
are what's going on here
okay and in this first
variation this first game
mike deviates
by playing the move bishop to h6
which as we spoke of is a very normal
idea here
white would love to exchange these
bishops
and weaken my king side
often usually this will be accompanied
by moves like g4 and h5 and trying to
storm the castle so notice how
unlike the regular king's indian defense
the kind of more traditional variations
white is the one fighting on the king
side not black so this is not usual for
this type of opening although it is
usual for the samish variation
but
i was still kind of getting more
familiar with the king's indian defense
at this point and so the move i played
was a5
and in standard lines of the king's
indian this is actually
a lot better this move makes more sense
what's the point
the point of a5 is sometimes to play to
a4
sometimes to stay on a5 and guard b4 but
regardless the point is to slow down
white's assault on the queen side this
is not so much an aggressive attacking
move in some cases it can be
but this is more meant to kind of slow
down these pawns advancing
fighting through on the queen side
and causing me some problems here as
black
but we're already witnessing my opponent
well he hasn't committed to it yet
he is you know trying to trade up these
bishops and it's very likely that he's
going to storm the castle with the pawns
which means i don't need to be slowing
him down on the queen side this isn't
really gaining me anything
um instead i need to be worried about
what's happening on the king side so
maybe a5 not the best move here it's
definitely showing signs of me auto
piloting this defense instead of
actually responding to what my opponent
is doing with this samish variation
and i want to briefly stop in this
position because instead of a5 i already
have a much better move um there's a
really beautiful tactical idea
that white can play or sorry the black
can play in this position
that kind of
shows one of the potential benefits of
this strange kind of knight a6 to c5
maneuver that we've experienced
so i want to see if anyone can find
a nice move for black in this variation
to gain a really almost decisive
advantage already
so take a second if you're watching this
later you can pause
if you're watching on youtube or
something you can pause this
and try and figure it out
but there's a really nice idea
and it looks like someone in the chat
has already found it uh luca
6768 well done uh yeah knight takes e4
beautiful move bam uh and you didn't
specify but it's important you take with
this knight on f6
and it looks like we're sacrificing a
piece here
um
but there's kind of a trick
we are threatening the queen so you have
to respond
if you take with the knight i'll take
back with mine and if you take with the
pawn
then it's going to be the same
uh either way
my goal now is to shoot for this
beautiful move queen to h4 check
kind of punishing the fact that white
has played f3 right normally in
variations uh f3 is not actually a
recommended move in the same issue it's
fine but you have to be careful with it
because it does expose this diagonal
and knight to s the knight from f taking
is very important because it opens up
this discovered uh attack from the queen
this queen is now going to be able to go
here and there's no time to tread off
this bishop because your queen is
hanging
if you take with the knight i'll take
back and the same thing is happening
you have to take and i'm going to get
this either way
and the problem here for white
is let's say a move like g3
and queen takes bishop
despite only being a pawn up right if
you look at everything on the position
i'm only up this f pawn right black
hasn't lost any pawns white sloth this
one and despite that the computer gives
this almost plus six or sorry minus six
but six points in black's favor meaning
we're almost better than we could just
have a rook and it wouldn't be as good
as this position
um so why is that why is this so good
for black
well
i think it's because so much of the
pressure that white is was trying to put
on has diffused without this f-pawn
there's really no more ideas of
stretching forward with h4 and g4 these
are going to be too slow and too unsafe
we're going to have enough coverage over
here to deal with it
also our ideas of pressing forward in
the center are going to continue just as
well
so f5 is coming very soon
and our pieces are going to get
activated
whether or not queens are traded light's
king is just kind of out in the open
queenside castling isn't going to help
that much
and our pieces are just so much better
developed right we have our king is
castled our bishop is nicely placed on
g7
this bishop can come out anytime soon
even maybe over here to help fight on
the queen side
and yeah white is just not doing very
well here so i already missed that nice
little tactical shot
um
and then some of that goes to show for
me piloting as well just like my
opponent but both of us could have been
punished a little better than what
happens in the game
so what does happen is i play a5
my opponent trades bishops king takes
and now h4 and this is another good move
i think this is less autopilot and more
um just maybe a slight positional
inaccuracy
because
strategically this isn't there's a
problem with this h4 move and it's that
it's
allowing me to block with something on
h5 now in the game i played pawn to h5
which seems like a very sensible move my
pawn is attacking g4 with my knight and
it's going to make it harder for white
to
punish this it's gonna be it's
especially harder for white to charge
ford with g4
so perhaps it's a little better to start
with the move g4 this way
now h5 you're just going to take it and
you're going to be quite happy
opening up this file to attack my king
later on
so this is going to limit my options a
little bit
but yeah h4 and i play h5 and it's
actually better to play the knight to h5
in my mind i thought this doesn't solve
the problem because i thought they were
just going to play pawn to g4
and now this knight just has to retreat
and looks kind of silly but actually in
this position knight to g3 is a very
solid move
forking the rook and bishop
and the problem i was like okay well
this piece is worth the same as this and
my knights had to move around and be
developed so why is it so good well the
problem is
if you want to save your rook you're
going to have to move it and when i take
this bishop you have to take with the
king which means you can't castle
anymore
so your king is going to be kind of
committed to this side of the board
which means if you really want to press
forward with these plans it's going to
be a double-edged sword your king's
going to be just as open as mine
and this is not so good for
white so knight h5 actually a very
strong move also stopping g4
um it's actually threatening to play
knight g3 right now even if you don't
play g4 so you have to find something uh
creative to get around this piece
but back to our game h5
and here my opponent plays bishop d3
perhaps another bit of a strategic
mistake
it's not really clear what this bishop
is doing um
since it's sitting right behind these
two pawns on e4 and c5 and it doesn't
look like either of them are going to be
traded anytime soon
this bishop is really just a tall pawn
not not the best you would rather have
this piece working on a long diagonal
where it can actually do something so i
think maybe on e2 it might be a little
better where it's actually supporting
the f3 pawn and supporting through it
vg4 square
trying to fight against my knight and
pawn
but bishop to d3
and i played the move c6 which is a very
important move happens a lot in
variations of the king's indian defense
and the idea here is one i'm threatening
to fight in the center and anytime i can
break open the center it's always going
to be in my advantage one because my
opponent hasn't castled and two because
the whole point of the opening is i'm
letting my opponent overextend in the
center
and
choosing to prioritize development
so if i can break through my opponent's
pride and joy here in this beautiful
pawn chain
then that's going to be a good idea
this is also with c6 i'm also opening up
this diagonal for the queen here to
maybe get involved and fight on the
queen side which could be relevant in
some positions especially if my opponent
decides to queenside castle
okay
knight to h3
and this move
i understand it because my opponent
wants to involve the knight in the
attack right this knight if it just goes
to e2 maybe it's not really as involved
it's going to take a little while i have
control of the f4 square so it's not
going to be able to jump there
and you probably don't want to push the
pawn to f4 since you spent a move
pushing it to f3 and you're still
fighting for g4
so
i understand why he doesn't want to play
this but i do think this would be better
uh served for the knight
maybe just getting the knight on e2
castling and then bringing your other
rook over to support g4 would probably
be a better way to continue
but his idea is probably to get this
knight into g5 and maybe put some
pressure on f7
and potentially even e6
just depending on how things go
however this actually gave me a nice
opportunity
and so i played the move c takes d5
and i think that this is actually a very
nice
move that i found i don't think if i'm
it's been a few years right i played
this game in 2020 so i don't remember
exactly my thought process here but
i do know that i found
it's actually a really nice move because
no matter how white recaptures here i
think black is very very happy
perhaps the most challenging is to take
with the c pawn my opponent chose to
take with the knight but we're going to
look at all three options
so if c takes d5
again the best way to recapture i think
probably the best most forcing
continuation here
would have been starting with knight
takes d3 check
and now a really really pretty move b5
which looks very unusual
um you'll see this in
some
benoni type structures where you're
sacrificing this pawn although usually i
think that's on b6 not p5
um
but the point is the same we're actually
happy to give up this pawn and either
way they take this piece
it's not going to be worth it for
example if queen takes b5
then something like bishop to a6
we are preventing light from king side
castling so we're cutting off that
option
um and wherever white goes let's say
something like queen to c6
we can continue by making threats on the
queen side here
and now
white can't castle king side wait
probably shouldn't castle queenside
so whatever white's doing the king is
going to be in trouble
opening up sacrificing this pawn to open
up these files is well worth it with our
opponents king not safe
um if they take with the knight instead
then the same idea you can play bishop
a6
now the knight's pinned and there's
actually no good ways to stop this right
very natural move a4 to defend
we can attack it again and still um stop
white from kingside castling so kind of
keeping the king up benko yes i said
bononi but benko thank you luca
keeping the king
locked here in the center once again you
can choose the queenside castle but are
you really going to put your king on
this open file that looks really nice
um
so something maybe like knight f to d2
to
allow the king to castle again
knight d7 castle
knight c5 jumping in hitting the queen
and
there's just a lot of problems here um
if something very simple like queen to
e3 then we're just happy to win this
pawn and continue winning on the queen
side
but there's a really kind of nice
tactical idea if they play queen to e2
trying to hold on to this pawn
then white has or sorry black has a
really nice tactical shot
to
gain a pretty serious advantage again in
this position
so
what would you do if you have
the
black pieces here once again feel free
to pause
uh if you're watching this on a
recording but if you're here live take a
second see if you can figure it out
it looks like
ashwinip 2013 and the chat has found it
i think you're a first time viewer so
welcome
um
and yeah really great move knight takes
a4
very nice undermining the defense of
this knight so we're sacrificing but
we're also going to win this night we've
removed the defender and once it is
captured we not only have won the pawn
right we just traded knights in on the
pawn but we also take on b5
skewer the queen and hit both rooks so
this is really a
quite ridiculously powerful move um the
computer actually i didn't even notice
it at first but when the computer looked
at this position and said yeah it
doesn't matter why it's going to move
the queen somewhere it doesn't matter
where and you don't even have to take
one of these rooks because when one
moves you take the other one so really
really nasty stuff here
okay but we've deviated a little off
course from the game so let's jump back
all of that is from this position
where i took here in the center
and we were saying c takes d5 is
probably the best for my opponent
because it is not easy to find this b5
move but it would be very very nice
if they take with the e pawn i think
things are a little simpler i can still
play very forcing by taking the bishop
and then playing this important move
bishop takes h3
normally i wouldn't want to open up this
file for the rook but in this case uh
it's well worth the compensation because
now i can play a simple move like knight
to d7
and threaten to put the knight on c5
where we just saw it's a very powerful
piece but i've also opened up this
discovery on the h4 pawn and there's
actually no good way to save this pawn
even a move like queen e4 won't work i
can still play knight to c5 and all of
these squares are covered
so you just cannot save the pawn
um so i'm going to be winning this and
blacks can't or sorry white's king once
again is far more exposed than mine is
so that would be if he takes d5 so for
those reasons my opponent chose to take
with the knight
but this actually leads to a problem as
well so if you have the black pieces
here take a look at this position
and see what you can find as the best
option
for
black how would you continue with the
black pieces here
and my recommendation is even if it's if
it's a tactic or not whenever you're
trying to calculate a position and find
the best moves you always want to start
with forcing moves so any moves that are
captures and checks because generally
they're going to force your opponent to
respond and they limit the number of
variations you have to think about
so start with the forcing moves see what
you can find
and just see if you can find the best
option for black to continue and gain a
really nice
advantage
all right and once again uh luca 6768 in
the chat has found a nice idea that i
found in the game
knight takes d5 so we start with a trade
that's going to force our opponent to
respond with a capture and by doing so
we also open up the line for this queen
remember f3 there is a weakness right
this diagonal is weak and now that my
opponent has played knight to h3 they're
actually blocking off the defender of
the h pawn
which with all these forcing moves gives
me time to find the right answer
my opponent recaptures
and this check
and now the move i played is i think
very strong and very natural the
computer actually likes a different
variation but it's very hard to
understand why
so let me show you what i played in the
game the move i played here was queen to
d4
i have uh the bishop is
attacked a lot
it's going to be hard to defend
and i'm up a pawn so i am happy to if my
opponent moves the bishop to just trade
pieces
this would not be a problem for me
my pieces are much more activated right
um this knight is not really doing much
compared to mine
my bishop can come out very soon and put
more pressure if it needs to
so
this is the move i played the computer
actually likes this kind of wild move
i'll just show you knight takes d3 which
to me looks like i'm giving up this
advantage but the point is after queen
takes d3 bishop to f5
and there's a lot of threats the queen
has to move
and it's either going to let go of
defending this square or this square
unless it goes to c3
if it goes to c3
then
probably i can just continue by bringing
one of my rooks to c8
putting it on this file and just causing
a lot of problems for my opponent
any other move i'm either going to bring
my queen to d4 or i'm just going to take
this pawn on c4 and i'm just kind of
crushing through my opponent's defenses
here
g4 g5 is also possible in the future
but yeah the move i played was queen to
d4
thinking i would just set up a
semi pin
and put more pressure on this piece
and unfortunately here my opponent made
a blunder
in this position my opponent played king
to c2
trying to defend and maybe open up lines
for the rooks
but unfortunately i think this is too
little too late
um
perhaps better would be a move like
knight to d2 defending
but after king to c2
white has a really you're sorry black
has a really beautiful way to
continue so see if you can find the best
move here for black again start with
your forcing options those are going to
be the most helpful when trying to
calculate the right answer
go ahead right on
uh d g oh d3 yeah knight takes d3 okay
queen takes
okay queen takes king
takes you're you're close
so see if you can find it so think again
this is the right first move knight
takes d3
and you're forcing the queen to take if
they don't want to lose the knight so
the queen's going to be on d3 what can
you do now
where
right yeah so a few people in the chat
have it um
yeah several ones uh and the first time
rng x freeze welcome um yeah the idea is
very nice for forcing move by taking
this piece and once white recaptures
bishop to f5 pinning the queen to the
king
this is a resignable position
my opponent is mike cummer and decided
to try and force me to prove that i
could win so uh the game continued but
it's just kind of a matter of technique
here so i'll kind of quickly go through
what happened queen takes
pawn takes
knight g5 king to g6
the knight retreats back
and i advance for with the pawns trying
to break through
b3
opening up a little bit of a potential
breathing room for the king but
unfortunately queen to d3
and i'm kind of creating my mating net
here
so in this position
uh it is i believe mate in
three
yep mate and three see if you can find
the best way to win
in three moves here for black
i'd like to move and get checkmating
three what would you do
uh okay so a3 check
uh the king
you can go either to a1 or c1 so let's
start with a1
yeah and it's actually the same either
way um so start with here and whichever
way the king goes
queen to c3 check
hits both of these squares and it's
gonna force king to be one
defended by the pawn we have checkmate
so this was the first game and i don't
feel bad about showing this uh because
i'm about to show a game where mike
learns from his mistakes and i don't
learn from mine um
in this follow-up game which happened
about six months later so about a year
later i think the first one was november
2020 and this one was may
2021. um we have the exact same opening
uh position
right so we have the king's indian
defense and my opponent plays the
same-ish variation with f3
we have bishop d3 queen d2 and i play my
kind of pet line with knight to a6 and
e5
but here my opponent learns so the last
time i don't know if he took a look at
our game and analyzed or took a look at
this position
but he stepped up a lot so no longer was
he autopiloting his moves right last
time bishop h6 was played which in the
game uh worked out okay at first but i
did have this nice tactical idea that i
missed
in this game
mike played g4
uh immediately attacking the king side
right
so no longer is he autopiloting this
time he is now thinking okay the point
of f3
the way he's choosing to play it
is to fight on the king side and he's
not wasting any time with that
and what did i do
well
i continued with a5
this was the same move i played last
time against bishop to h6 right again my
plan was the same i'm going to stop you
from advancing on the queen side but you
can already see
i'm not paying attention to what's
happening in this game i'm playing my
very normal king's indian moves
unfortunately my opponent is not playing
very normal king's indian he's playing
the same-ish variation
so i have to be responding to what he's
doing instead i choose to autopilot and
he's not worried about fighting on the
queen side so this pawn
if it's not a defensive piece i can try
and use it offensively but i'm not
really in a situation to do that yet and
i'm especially not able to do that
faster than he is because he's already
pushed these pawns
the other thing i want to notice is
notice how he starts with g4
in the last time
we played
he ended up playing h4 first and we
talked about that gave me a little
opportunity right i had this outpost on
h5 where i could kind of blockade with
the pawn or the knight
and cause him some problems we looked at
how the knight was a little better right
if h4 and h5 there's chances of knight
to g3
where i'm hitting these two pieces and
stopping him from castling
so he's learned quite a bit
i'm guessing he did do some studying
because yeah this is quite a change
an a5 i have not done some studying so
uh this is the problem with autopilot
and rather than just assessing what your
opponent is playing
h4 and now
okay now his pawns are really starting
to come for me
and i'm not really sure what to do here
so i just continue with what i think is
the best idea and i play a4
right i'm thinking oh i'm just going to
keep advancing this pawn i'm going to
threaten the queen side and i'm going to
fully stop him from attacking me over
there
that's great my plan is going so well
um
well a few problems one my opponent
hasn't committed to castling queenside
right just like last time and last time
it caused him some problems not castling
too early this time
well i don't think he needs to because
i'm not really putting pressure on his
king or on the center if i'm playing
good moves like c6 where i'm trying to
break through the center um maybe
eventually b5 like we saw that idea last
time then that might be something worth
considering is castling trying to get
safe
um maybe even getting your pieces
developed and uh kingside castling in
some cases maybe not
um but i haven't given him a reason to
do that yet
and his threats of advancing on the king
side are very very significant
so instead of a4 i probably needed to
play h5
um and the computer says it's okay here
i think practically this is hard to
defend still
whether he pushes and just gains a lot
of pressure this way or whether he takes
and opens up this file
either way
i think again it's probably close to
equal white being a little better but i
do think practically this is a lot
harder to defend
so h5 would have been maybe a better
move maybe even c6
but
a4 is just not really continuing with
any type of plan
that's going to help me out
h5
okay
now it's become very obvious to everyone
here
that
my plan of advancing the a pawn is silly
right it's just not helping
uh my own strategy in any way and it's
giving my opponent time to really put
pressure on my king
so at this point
with white's advance bearing down i have
to find something to do and i start to
crumble under the pressure in this
position i played the move rook to e8
which is not good right for the same
reason that a4 isn't good
this rook on e8 isn't actually doing
anything um these pawns are very locked
up and it's unlikely my opponent's gonna
try and break through with f4 anytime
soon so it's pretty unlikely that this
rook is gonna be able to
do anything strong on this line i would
probably rather have it here on f8 where
it's defending f7
perhaps eventually i might try and play
f6 or f5 just to create some counter
play over here
maybe you know force these pawns to
trade somewhere they don't want to
but either way i think it's more
valuable here as a defensive resource
than on e8 where it's trying to be
aggressive but
just not really doing so
so again rook to e8 not the best idea
frantic spawn and with the walls of my
castle crumbling i'm forced to respond
and i take back with the f-pawn here um
i do think this is better than taking
with the h-pawn
when you are under attack
you want to create as many barriers for
your opponent as possible
so
um
yeah luke i'll talk about that in a
minute because i am trying to create an
escape plan but i don't think work to e8
was for exactly that purpose um but but
that does happen very soon
um but i think taking with the h1 would
probably have been worse because now if
my opponent can set up some opportunity
to trade
i wouldn't take or i'm not saying this
is the best variation
you can already see this is actually i
think in this particular position made
is unstoppable
um
well no i guess i can play knight here
and then
run away here so in this case i would be
able to escape but still not good not
ideal to just give up a night like that
for nothing um
but the point is after f takes
then that plan is not so good my
opponent actually plays bishop to h6
which is a mistake this allows me to
equalize the position
even though it looks very strong
the problem is i have this pawn here on
h7 and so i have one more defensive
resource between my opponent's rook and
eventually their queen and mike king
so keeping this as an extra just
something in the way is usually going to
be helpful on the defense even if it's
not perfect
but bishop h6 i want to talk about why
this is a mistake
because it's very hard to see why
and even knowing the idea it's not
immediately obvious why but there's
actually a really
nice defensive resource that black can
use
in the game i tried the move b5
i didn't see that i had something
defensive to survive and so i thought in
desperation i just need to create
counter play anywhere right i know i'm
just sacrificing a pawn but i was hoping
maybe if i can open up some lines i can
maybe get something involved on the the
queen side i can maybe get my pieces to
start fighting i wasn't really sure but
i knew that i needed to get something
away from the king side so this was my
thought
um the actually
really amazing defensive idea is to take
the bishop and allow queen takes
and then to play this move rookie seven
which is again defending the pawn here
um i was worried i didn't see rookie
center i was worried that this knight is
the only defender of the pawn
once g5 is advanced i'm just going to be
crushed and it's going to have to run
and checkmate is coming very soon
uh and i'm even here worried about ideas
of like the knight coming in and
attacking more but actually the computer
is okay defending this because knight to
h3 is a little too slow
going to f8
and i'm actually just barely able to
fight off white's attack i do still
think white is maybe slightly better
but somehow black is surviving here
if instead of knight to h3 then g5 is
played then the knight can just go to h5
and there's not really tricks of sacking
um
we're gonna look at some sacrifice ideas
later but this is actually gonna you
know be survivable enough for
black
but instead i didn't see that and i
played b5 so trying to respond
and my opponent just continues very
normally very safely bishop takes
king takes
queen to h6 check forced
and my idea i move king to f7
i think king h8 is very obviously a bad
move trapping my king here in the corner
uh this is going to be
very soon checkmate um king to g8 is
apparently about as good but i think
king to f8 is more natural um with the
idea of yeah trying to run away
somewhere just escape all the madness
that's happening over here
and here again i missed a really
excellent defensive resource
um g5 was played and i thought in this
position
there's really nothing to do because
once this knight moves
um
if it doesn't move it's getting taken
but wherever it moves queen takes h7 is
coming
and my thing unfortunately it just
doesn't have time to escape because
this pawn on d5 is really nicely
guarding
uh all of these potential escape squares
this is maybe showing also why earlier
fighting with a move like c6 is really
helpful it can give my king maybe a
little bit of a buffer zone to sneak
through here and also try and fight back
in the center
but after g5 the move i played was rook
to h8 i kind of resigned myself that i'm
losing this piece and i just needed to
stop the queen from breaking through
and after a move like takes
uh now i have a threat here on g7
so i played queen takes f6
but i want to give you all a shot
at finding a better way to defend this
position kind of a miraculous way i i
didn't believe it worked
until i kind of looked through some
computer lines but i want to see what
you can find as a really uh last resort
effort that actually not only
saves the game but
gives black something to fight for
so see if you can find a way to survive
this devastating attack with the black
pieces what are your thoughts
h4
uh to h here yeah
yeah so knight h5 and um someone chat
saw this too knight g8 does not work but
knight h5 does and the idea here that i
missed i was thinking well this is silly
i'm just going to lose this pawn and
everything is lost what i missed is now
the knight comes to g7
blocking the check
and it doesn't matter that this file is
fully open there's nothing left over
there to attack
um and
amazingly in this position
white just has no more way to attack my
king
there's not enough resources available
to go after this pawn
i can kind of defend against any of them
yeah somehow i am just surviving this
position
really miraculously
i think kind of a natural looking move
here is
oops see if i can get it uh rook in here
to attack this pawn
but queen takes g5 right this pawn is
not defended
so
this somehow just
keeps me alive um amazingly
uh and there's also no idea of
sacrificing the rook to take the knight
normally this is something you'll see in
kind of beginner intermediate games
um
but somehow even here um
black has
at least survivable chances i do think
the computer gives white a slight edge
um
but regardless i will say on a practical
level this is very hard to defend as
black right your king is extremely
exposed right there this pawn is coming
through so technically this is
survivable
but we're not computers we're humans so
i don't know that i would still want to
get in this position
that said
it is it would have been a lot better
than what i ended up getting in so
we'll take that for what it's worth so
work to h8 trying to hold on to h7
uh context knight obviously uh
threatening
check so queen takes f6
and now uh there are ways to continue to
press for an attack here but my opponent
just took a knight
so queen to h4 and my opponent is uh
deciding
if we can just simplify this position
trade a bunch of pieces
i will be very content
so
for those who don't know if you are um
more on the beginner side and just
haven't heard when you are
down in material generally you don't
want to trade your pieces uh because
what's going to happen is we can just
imagine i go along with this trade and
so the queens go off the board and let's
just pretend we keep trading the knights
go off the board the rooks go off the
board
um and everything is traded
eventually you can see what happens is
my opponent still has this extra piece
left that i don't have and all i have in
exchange for it is i think i'm up a pawn
somewhere
yeah i have two pawns over here one of
them is past but it's also a rook pawn
so
that should be a pretty easy win for my
opponent with that extra piece that i
don't have so when you are down in
material generally you don't want to
trade it's going to make it easier for
your opponent when you have less
resources on the flip side if you're up
material trading is a great thing so i
think this is a very good practical move
for my opponent um and i decided not to
accept i play queen to g7 trying to hang
on to the material
um
and so yeah i declined the train
my opponent now takes on b5
punishing that much earlier mistake
right very long a long time ago i played
b5 as this desperation idea hoping to
give myself some counter play
and after all of that all of these
forcing threats over here against my
king finally my opponent says okay well
i guess i'm just going to take this
piece you gave me
and there were some minor inaccuracies
that continued from here um but
generally the game
just went fairly straightforward so i'm
not going to spend too much more time on
analysis i will show you how mike ended
up winning this game
uh bishop d7 i decided to give up this
pawn
so that i could develop my piece
and maybe create some counter play
rook to c8 perhaps it would have been a
little better to play rook to b8 and
maybe threaten something and maybe
eventually i can try and double these
brooks or sorry just put them next on
these files
but rook to c8
knight to e6
a little bit strange um centralizing the
night but it is i am able to trade but
again my opponent is up a piece so he's
deciding
well it's okay if i give a little bit of
the material back because i'm still up
the piece so in the end it's still a
little better for my opponent even
though i get this pawn back
um i'm still at a disadvantage because
i've had to trade these pieces away
uh rook to c1
h5 trying to keep my opponent from
advancing in
queen to f2
rook to v8
and
again these moves fairly simply continue
opponent wants to trade again this is a
great move because i really don't have a
way to save that bishop
c8 trade and
in this position i ran out of time
but i am also down a full piece
so my opponent played extremely well
and uh punished me
and really learned from his mistakes
right so if we go back and look at just
the critical moments of these two games
what i want to emphasize is
you want to be careful when you get to
that stage and i think last week i
talked about finding your openings and
we talked about setup based openings and
sequence based openings
one of the things you want to be careful
of regardless of what kind of opening
you end up playing
is
not to fall into this trap of autopilot
you want to really respond to how your
opponent is playing right knight to a6
and to c5 is not something you see very
often especially in the same variation
so i would not be surprised at all for
my opponent not to be ready for it and
just to continue with normal ideas
as we saw um again i didn't punish this
card i was also autopiloting but there
are some really big issues with just
playing on autopilot here
that my opponent could have suffered
from and eventually does suffer from
regardless right because he's not really
pressing in the exact right ways
if we contrast that with what happened
in
the later game where again my opponent
had the opportunity to think about what
i'd done
analyze his own game
and come up with a better plan
we see that i'm the one who is still
autopiloting
and my opponent instead is playing very
very precise very strong moves
that caused me a lot of problems and
obviously we're not computers so neither
of us played perfectly in either game
there were still chances for both sides
but
my opponent played a lot better and
really learned
from his previous game's mistake so if
anything you learn from today i would
say is
one analyzing your games is extremely
helpful
because it can help you see what you've
done and how to change it and you're not
always going to be playing the same
people but i suspect a lot of you have
friends either in person or online who
you play with
and being able to kind of start
recognizing their habits what they play
especially their openings and think
about how you respond it's a really good
way to improve right
finding the best plans forward here
this versus this
is really a very strong uh way to
continue
so yeah that's kind of it
uh so thank you for tuning in and i hope
to see you again next week but yeah this
has been beginner breakdown with alex
mullering and
thanks